so when you got hired at snl first i
mean that must have been thrilling yes
you were back at 30 rock did that feel
like full circle
yes it definitely did i mean there were
so many things like i remembered how
weird the elevators are that like you
press the button you know like
it was really cool to come back in that
capacity i honestly
my past got me less access than my
intern pass
[Laughter]
but yeah it was really cool to come back
in that way and and be in that building
and yeah it was definitely felt very
full circle when you started at snl were
you aware of the snl interns and were
you like oh you know i'm gonna be nice
to them yes i always tried to be so nice
to the interns and you know the thing
that i remembered from conan
and this is funny because then it sort
of changed for me but
what i used to say to the interns was
i'd say the thing that used to stress me
out when i was an intern was that when
people had asked for coffee with like
milk like from starbucks or whatever i
would get so stressed about how much
milk to add and i was like just so you
guys know it doesn't matter like add as
much milk as you want and then like
and then like as i was there for longer
i'd be like have a little more milk
but yeah but in general that was the one
thing i used to say to them to keep to
like not stress them out and the thing i
remember about conan which he did which
actually was a great thing to do in
retrospect is he would ask for
like a large coffee with like a cup of
milk
so he could he could add it to him so he
could add it himself and yeah like that
is such a nice thing to do because then
as an intern you really are like he
decides i don't have to worry about it
it's like getting someone a gift card
it's like you don't have to
but like with the other p i remember i
was always so stressed so that was like
the one thing i would tell them to like
at that age you don't drink coffee
really and or you don't know what kind
of thing you don't know and you think
like these are these fancy adults and
they probably like have such specific
things that they want and like you just
don't want to some of them are 23 years
old they really live
also
back then there were only two types of
milk now yeah that's true
oh my gosh yeah so you really want to
put people at ease and just
yeah yeah
so i'd always try and be extra nice to
the interns because yeah it is yeah it's
like when you've been when you've worked
in food service and you're like i i know
i get it i'm gonna be nice to to the
wait staff yeah yeah if um
interns would ask you for advice on
how to like
get to where you were yeah sometimes
they would what to do with curly hair
[Laughter]
sometimes they would and
i would just say like depending on what
you want to do i would just be like you
know write all the time have a lot of
stuff written and i said like if you
want to perform like do as many shows as
you can and um the other thing that i
really respected from the interns was
always when they were just like really
there were certain interns that i really
saw myself in and it was all the interns
that were like
really wanting to do a good job and
really kind of like like i just i i also
think there's just like something to
like treating
even though like comedy and stuff is so
silly is like treating the whole
business like a job and like and like
being professional and all that kind of
stuff and being
kind and just like you know that kind of
stuff too is just like um and by the way
these these interns were like in a job
so but but i but in terms of like
going into comedy i would just say like
you know get on stage as much as you can
and and a lot of stuff that honestly
writers told me when i was at conan it
was like i have the stuff ready so that
like when you do get those opportunities
you're you're ready for them right don't
wait for the job to start doing the work
yeah before you get the job exactly